hey welcome wait wait no it's not oh my
god every every single time I open this
game I'm like yeah I'm gonna play roller
coaster taken three and then i use a SWD
and put in instead of the arrow keys
which are obviously very old school and
well controls at this point but every
time that just opens up windows so
that's why that happened I'm sorry so do
I have the haunted house already and I
do and for once I'm really glad to build
a haunted house because I'm kind of
running out of ideas in this bike and I
might as well tune that big part over
there into some kind of big entrance
path I can't do that now it does look as
if this thing is a bit too close to the
roller coaster over there so I'm going
to move it just one tile so it doesn't
block the beautiful sight seeing of the
roller coaster over there and then I'm
going to take that thingy that path and
see if I can into place back which I
can't it still doesn't line up I'm just
gonna dig into the ground over here yeah
it's not going to be too much fun to
place one of those to play one of those
on parks in which you can't edit
anything like what's it called again
Rainbow Valley i think is the name
because there's something about the fact
that i don't think that any of the
scenarios in walla coaster tycoon one
are actually incredibly hard I mean
they're a challenge but I've rarely ever
failed for any if I ever did but the
issue is with some parts I always I
always kind of want to go for realism
and nice looking parks but it's
sometimes just impossible and that's the
case with for example Rainbow Valley
because you can't delete any of the
trees or do any terraforming not sure if
I should really talk about this already
because that's going to happen in a very
the later stage but whatever I still
like to talk about that ok let's see
more crunch rubs that's very important
you can not forget about the ground
foliage
which if you've been in the roller
coaster tycoon 3 community for a very
long time of you or you've known me for
a very long time you'll realize that
ranch robbery is almost so infamous that
it's turn into an inside joke kind of
lse of these bushes and perhaps another
handyman because you know I can afford
it anyway and I keep seeing puke on my
paths which is something I'm not very
fond of and I can even see some
destroyed benches already dammit guests
for some reason a junior coaster is
sickening to these people so I'm gonna
assign one handy man just for this
little area okay so that's cool loads of
people on the rowing boats it's not
actually critical yeah I definitely need
to meet some paths up to this area
because I've got this beautiful coaster
and I definitely kind of want to open it
640 is going to be the price 6 40 euros
is a ridiculous amount of money I'm so
surprised that people are even willing
to pay this and and gladly and actually
going on all these right and all that um
I do need to move the just for moving
the entrance you're going to close the
whole ride you know that's how it goes
and then you oh oh wait no nevermind um
you don't lose your statistics okay
let's see what else it's raining that
sucks
and every time like I or somebody else
says it's raining and my brain just says
is a raining man just quite stupid I
don't know that was something I thought
when I was younger but it still doesn't
want to go away and when I was younger I
always thought I was funny when I was
thinking it's raining men meant that it
was raining like men as in humans but I
would I was so shocked to find out that
it actually meant exactly that and then
there was a gay song well whatever um
you know yeah i'm just going to change
this because i don't know the in-game
kind of underground text is not even all
that bad but there's something about in
game and standard stuff that the game
comes with if you don't change anything
I just ignores that just annoys me
sometimes now this ride effin Utley
needs some brushing up in terms of
foliage mostly in terms of Grouch
robbery so I'm going to place exactly
that this was very necessary for this
ride oh yes the sounds summons are kind
of like the sprites in this game they're
not even all that realistic a lift Hill
in real life definitely doesn't sound
like this and I don't know what kind of
screams they got for those games but
these screams are not realistic at all
but there's just a churn nostalgic can't
effective to it now it still sounds
awesome despite how terrible it may be
I'm going to place these trees because
I'm just a huge fan of these things they
look awesome have a nice little texture
to it
and I don't know if these were also an
open man and I mean in transport tycoon
but they might have been I know that
many things win this game whoa let's see
I do kind of want to place a fence just
because I'm a fence crazy person not
over there though looks kind of awkward
if it if it's just one square there's a
certain minimum it seems for the amount
of squares that offense should have
before it's actually a real fence
offensive one square is kind of awkward
not really one time fan and I'm already
opening a path over there even though
the roller coasters not opened yet I
should probably work on that the queue
is going to be all the way over here now
that's actually kind of a weird kegel
and the path is going to be right there
that's a bit awkward very awkward
actually I'm gonna change that I'm gonna
make it a more classical q like that
that's probably a cue that's way too
long term I can make that a bit shorter
now I still have space over here to do
something with don't really know what
but you know might always try something
and I'm actually going to move this path
to so I can actually make this look a
bit better over here come on you can do
it there we go it's always a bit a bit
of puzzle puzzle if you really want to
do your path work like that because Q is
a normal paths don't really mix that
well it's kind of a not so great feature
of the game play in this game but really
that's just one of the few new tricks
that you can choose from this game which
aren't that great but other than that
it's just an amazing game and it still
marvels me after all these years hmm
right I don't know what to do next I
mean this rider oh wait its knowledge
been opened wow that sounds kind of
stupid and I definitely should change
the color scheme something like this and
then the first vehicles going to be
green because I don't know people are
already entering holy [ __ ] noise is not
as beautiful um yeah should i hook this
up to the other path is the problem now
I'm having with this path is that it's
most likely just going to confuse people
because it's such a huge part and
there's nothing to really do on it
doesn't lead anywhere or something like
that and this is quite an empty area
which I don't like that so she's gonna
film it up with some trees look like
that and one of these things nice and i
don't think i can get this type of tree
so that's an issue so i should
definitely not remove that tree now
there is a little bit of space over here
on which i can place a flat ride but
nothing else really in this area so i'm
going to eventually open this up when
i'm going to place a flat right over
here so i actually have a kind of
connection thingy is part the will serve
as a connection but right now it'll
serve more as a distraction than a
connection so I'm definitely not going
to open that up yet because terrible
guests AI
right I think that's good there is such
a thing as overdoing your foliage and I
definitely don't want to do that and
this is a full train already i don't
know this is the first rain on this ride
but as beautiful just after opening
until we got off the train and already
making quite a bit of profit don't know
how much this thing is making well not
that bad and what else do we have still
have plenty of loan left don't know if
I'm actually making a profit on this
pike which might turn into an issue
where where can I am I i see i can i
keep losing money but right now i'm
actually making profit so that's good
the only issue is that every month i
build more than iron but is that really
an issue i don't think so as long as the
park is going to look good how much time
do I have for this again year three yeah
there was definitely enough time to fill
up this area that I have right now with
more interesting stuff that is a as long
as I get new rides which I should have
and there is the spiral slide which I
might want to place over here just to
play something over here so I'm going to
open up this area
and nice little spiral slide yes which
is the crowning achievement of
capitalism because everyone that dares
to pay a lot of money for this ride even
though it's incredibly stupid really
it's only a slide and you can ask
ridiculous amount of money for this
thing like how much you cannot ask for
this still awaiting test results
whatever next people on the rise going
to be young one now as it a stupid oh
whatever i'm just going to open it it's
going to be the slide because i don't
care about usernames and for what
attraction names seriously i do care
about my color schemes though and this
is definitely not one that i really like
so I'm going to change that into that
we're decent and decent but are they
very similar to what I've place already
yeah i'm just going to go with this and
some small trees over here let's see the
test results 180 and it's increasing it
decreasing what it's still increasing
with more trees okay let's see still
increasing ah whatever
I didn't know that trees had such a huge
impact they shouldn't have I don't know
how that happened I mean yeah scenery
has an impact on the excitement rating
but it really shouldn't matter that
you're placing whoa okay okay Oh 190
then yeah because I'm just having a few
trees around the slide makes it twenty
cent more worth to ride definitely now
I'm going to hook this up because before
I actually getting lost right now and
see what else we're going to get a chair
lift which is an utterly and completely
useless thing in this game so good job
there I don't know if I know there's no
place where I could actually use that
you know if you really want to do it and
I've done this in the path you can do
the fun thing and actually place a
chairlift over the lake but right now I
don't have any place to place two
stations for that so that's an issue and
I'm definitely not going to try doing it
let's see eat more of this tree on the
coaster in the way mom over there so
okay good yeah that's also one issue I
suppose the isometric view as nice as it
looks on as nostalgic as it feels
sometimes you really can't see [ __ ] and
that might be an issue from time to time
another issue that I'm having right now
is how I'm going to fill up this area
because it's too small to fill up with a
flat wide but it's too big to fill up
with anything else I think I'm just
going to do the scenery thing and just
build a path like that and put this
information thing in the middle or a
bathroom now just do that it doesn't go
around it it's nicely but no it's still
something still filling up the void
tall hedges around that and yes I am
very fond of my hedges and I'm still
placing way too many hedges in my pikes
oh well I just like doing that and this
little fence because I have to use this
too often and I keep Miss lacing fences
very good at Mac and I suppose this
place could also be used for some
something it was a little fountain or
something like that not bad and some
more ground shrubs more ground white
note other ones the these lighter ones
and the dark ones are going to go over
here very nice and some smaller trees I
suppose some of these trees oh wait no
no they don't they look kind of weird I
don't know really I kind of want to have
a very small tree but it shouldn't have
too weak those weird like colors that I
shouldn't have in here this one doesn't
look too great either hmm yeah I think
I'm just gonna go with this instead not
three though kind of looks awkward or
maybe I should have two different trees
or two of these you know what I suppose
that's the best thing I shouldn't I
shouldn't keep meddling with that okay
so that's all fine many people are still
riding the roller coaster which is an
excellent name this ride is imported
straight from Japan including its cheesy
title and how much money is it making
over ten thousand dollars in that of
dollars i keep seeing that euros of
course because this is Europa and he's
going to mow the grass but not really he
shouldn't do that I think this is it I
don't know what else to do I currently
have no development going on those the
chairlift which is completely useless
right now at least I can place a very
small one and make a bit of profit off
of it but that would feel mean I mean
seriously it wouldn't it wouldn't lead
anywhere it would serve no point so yeah
I guess I'll see you guys next time in
which I have no clue what I'm actually
going to do so I maniacally build my new
roller coaster like fill up this big
area over here with an exciting roller
coaster like oh wait single real veligit
I was so stupid that's the single real
roller coaster not the single real
inverted roller coaster that's a
different thing that's even worse there
are none of those in the world excepting
like a black boar I'm Pleasure Beach I
think which is a very small and really
not like anything like the game but yeah
I'm gonna see you all next time so bye